je l'entends bois
dans la touffeur koceku d'accord j'ai
prouvé quoi déjà
pour le plaisir de la bouche travailler
sa langue et faire venir les mondes je
prends mon pied en parlant des fois je
suis pas encore un intellectuel mais
j'arrive quand même à jouer par la
tomate fraîche ou dans l'odeur genre
lazar mazars mazars c'est quoi alors
hasard zarma pour laisser francs la maaf
hakim seconde qui que je trouve canon et
chaque mois question 10 de sandrine
tu connais jamais vu mon fils amour
barlin ça passe par la bouche c'est vrai
petit bisou pas sans âme où un
embrassant tu remplaces marabout changé
c'est bon nous on aime bien rangé ça
passe par la bouche c'est bon culture de
langue et on pourrait dire la langue au
chat par exemple la langue à langue
multiraciale alors on mélange la langue
de choc des cultures
c'est quoi ça c'est langue
internationale c'est largo la déchirer
le magic
oui bah dans paris faut déchirer le
match il lui c'est un terminator
j'ai plein de copains aura pas de
problème problème tu mon style du moment
qu'il ya pas de problème tiens voilà
encore un mot très très cher on prône la
tête c'est de l'art gaulon la langue
bouche et non et ça ça ça donne quoi tu
peux parler la levée des bouchers c'est
que les gars des gros mots rires ah
ouais comme quoi par exemple tu peine du
likès ouais ça veut dire quoi ça qui pue
du cul bac ça
alcool colao mactac aulas
gaudreault non pas que je suis clean je
suis propre en fait c'est le mot anglais
mais je suis bien je suis mais c'est au
sens figuré non non non tous les jours
ou alors c est dans ta tête aussi je
veux décline dans ta tête je suis
toujours clim
maintenant qu à la télé on voit que des
trucs où il faut parler en anglais ça
vous choque moi ça défonce même ça me
choque pas ça me défonce
[Musique]